How do you teach a parrot to dance?
Or a cockroach to hit its mark?
Well, Hollywood has a range of tricks
to train these stars
and every other kind of
insect and animal imaginable.
Trainers: Come on, baby!
Right here, come on!
Narrator: From penguins to house spiders,
let's look at how 10 different
members of the animal kingdom
prepare for some of
Hollywood's biggest roles.
Scout Raskin: Good boy!
Narrator: These goats,
named Gizmo and Doc,
can shake hooves, give high fives,
jump on a person, balance on their back,
and even walk on their hind legs.
Scout: Walk, walk, walk, walk, walk.
Narrator: Their trainer, Scout Raskin,
says they're just as smart as dogs,
and maybe even smarter in one area:
object permanence.
That's the ability to know
that an object continues to exist
even if it disappears from your view.
If Scout needs a goat to go
to a certain spot on set,
she'll hide treats in that
area and show the goat,
but not let it enjoy them just yet.
Then, when the director calls "action,"
the goat will go right
to the hidden treats.
Not because it's sniffing
them out like a dog would,
but because it remembers
the treats are there.
Other tricks rely on
goats' natural movements.
Like in the horror movie "The Witch,"
where this goat bounces sideways --
that movement is actually
an expression of joy.
And getting a goat to
rear on its hind legs,
like in this scene,
mimics how goats naturally
reach leaves on tree branches.
Scout usually uses a
grabber tool with a treat
to have the goat get up on its hind legs.
Then, slowly, she adds
in two-legged walking.
But these animals can also be dangerous.
On the fourth day of filming "The Witch,"
Charlie, who played Black Phillip,
rammed his horns into
actor Ralph Ineson's ribs,
something that happened in the movie
but wasn't supposed to
happen in real life.
Ineson spent the rest
of the five-week shoot
on pain killers.
The incident led to the movie's director,
Robert Eggers, to say after filming,
"I don't recommend making
a movie with a goat
in a major role,"
and, "You can't train a goat."
You can, Scout says,
but you have to start when
the goat is very young,
less than two months old,
and practice nearly every day.
A lot of people don't like spiders --
Can we panic now?
Narrator: Which makes
them a great character
in Hollywood movies.
But how do you get these critters
to do what you want on screen?
You get them to react to
stimuli in predictable ways,
according to the
entomologist Steven Kutcher.
Steven is Hollywood's go-to bug guy,
who's worked on films from "Jurassic Park"
to "Spider-Man" and orchestrated
this spider attack in "Arachnophobia."
For that movie, he got the
spiders to run where he wanted
by stringing extremely
thin wires on the set.
These wires vibrated faster
than the eye can see,
forming lanes that the
spiders would run through.
For this pivotal "Spider-Man" scene,
Steven staged a "spider Olympics"
to find the right actor for the part.
He settled on this type of house spider
and had an artist paint its body
radioactive red and blue.
When they shot the scene,
Steven was above Tobey Maguire
holding the spider on a paintbrush.
It crawled along the edge of the brush,
and when it reached the end,
Steven tapped the brush to make the spider
drop down towards Tobey.
Only the bite was CGI.
A peppered cockroach named Nancy
played a roach with the voice of God
in the horror movie "Saint Maud."
But Nancy couldn't have
pulled off the role
without her trainer, Grace Dickinson.
Here, Grace is holding Pepper,
Nancy's sister who served
as her acting double
for "Saint Maud."
Grace says cockroaches are scent-oriented
and naturally explore
the places they're in.
Before a roach's big filming day,
she'll typically practice
leading the insect
from point A to point B
by repeatedly guiding it down a path
that ends in something
sweet, like a pot of jelly
or a sip of nectar or honey water.
Grace says cockroaches in general
have naturally even temperaments,
but since they're small creatures,
sudden light or temperature
changes can stress them out.
If a roach performer is having a bad day,
it might make hissing noises,
drop a stink bomb,
or try to fly off or run away.
So Grace brings a rigged habitat on set,
where her actors can get
some much-needed rest
between filming sessions.
In battle scenes from older
movies, like this one,
you may see horses
falling head over heels.
That's because battlefield sets
were lined with trip wires,
a dangerous and inhumane
practice that's now illegal.
Today, horses are trained
to fall to the ground
in battle scenes, and to do it safely.
First, the horse has to get comfortable
lying down on its side.
Some trainers will help this process along
by first lifting their horse's
legs and laying them down.
Then they'll walk the
horse and lay them down
over and over until the
horse can do it alone.
Eventually, the horse will
be able to lie down on cue
in one fluid motion.
The faster they do it, the
more dangerous it gets,
so trainers will usually make sure
the horses land on a cushioned bed,
like two feet of soft,
natural material called peat,
or, in the case of "Game of
Thrones," padded mattresses.
Productions use padding
in chase scenes as well,
like this horse and motorcycle chase
in "John Wick 3."
Trainers laid 400 feet of rubber tarps
on the streets of New York City
and fitted the horses' hooves
with rubber horseshoes.
This helped the horses maintain balance,
so they'd feel comfortable
galloping at full speed.
When it comes to training birds,
not all species are created equal.
[clicker clicks]
Benay Karp: Good boy.
Narrator: Of the 3,200 trained birds
used in "The Birds,"
Alfred Hitchcock said the
ravens were the cleverest,
while the seagulls were the most vicious.
Back in 1963, the seagulls on the film
were reportedly fed a
mixture of wheat and whiskey
to get them to stand around for scenes.
Luckily, training approaches
have improved since then.
Hope you folks figure this thing out!
Narrator: Here, a grey parrot named Babs
is learning how to dance.
[clicker clicks]
Benay: Good bird.
Narrator: The thing making that sound --
[clicker clicks]
is a clicker,
a tool trainer Benay Karp
uses to provide birds
with instant feedback
after they do something correctly.
Benay teaches her parrots to be
as quiet as possible on set
so they don't step on other actors' lines,
rewarding good behavior with treats
like frozen strawberries.
Parrot: Thank you!
Narrator: Often, though,
productions want parrots
to look like they're talking in a scene.
In that case, Benay will
put a little peanut butter
in the parrot's mouth.
As the bird smacks on the peanut butter,
it looks like delivering dialogue,
so the production can put
in voiceover later on.
Parrot: Enhanced voice recognition.
Narrator: One of the most
common production requests
for birds is a basic flight
from point A to point B.
Or, in the case of this penguin,
a waddle.
Trainers: Hi, baby! Right here! Come on!
Narrator: But it can get even more complex
for some actors.
In preparation for a Kind bar commercial,
this crow learned to fly a package
about 12 feet to the porch,
leave the package in a bowl,
give a little jog,
then fly back out to its crate.
For teaching this type
of sequence of commands,
Benay uses a concept called back-chaining.
That means she'll teach
the last behavior in a sequence first,
so flying back from the porch,
and then work backwards
to get the first step,
which is bringing the
package to the porch.
This is Crystal, a capuchin monkey
who's appeared in a long
string of movies and shows
after her breakout role
in "George of the Jungle."
Her trainer, Tom Gunderson,
estimates that she recognizes
60 different words in English,
including complex commands like
"hands on head," "open your mouth,"
"bare your teeth," and
"stick out your tongue."
Director: Action.
Trainer: Touch. Open.
[Crystal squeaks]
Bang.
Narrator: In one of the biggest
challenges of her career,
Crystal even learned to pretend-puff
a fake ceramic cigarette
for "The Hangover Part II."
The smoke was digitally added later on.
Despite this extensive training,
Crystal still isn't potty-trained.
Her character in "The
Hangover" wore a costume,
which conveniently hid the diaper
she had on underneath.
But when Crystal plays a wild monkey,
like in "Failure to Launch"
or "Night at the Museum,"
she can't wear diapers,
which means things can get messier.
She actually pooped on Robin Williams
when they were filming
"Night at the Museum."
Luckily, incidents like that haven't hurt
Crystal's rep in the industry.
[snake hisses]
A movie like "Snakes on a Plane"
required a snake wrangler as
experienced as Jules Sylvester,
who's handled reptiles
for over 350 movies.
Jules refers to what he does
as "reptile management"
rather than "training."
He says, "You can't make a snake
do anything they don't want to do."
What you can do is tap into
the snake's innate behaviors.
Snakes generally like to
move from warm to cool spaces
and from light to dark,
so wranglers can direct a snake's movement
by manipulating the
temperature and lighting.
Plus, if you put any
ground-running species,
like a corn snake,
on an elevated place,
like an airplane seat,
it will make its way down to the ground.
Others, like rat snakes
and pythons, like to climb,
so they'll seek out higher surfaces.
Jules took advantage of
these natural inclinations
to create some chaotic
shots in "Snakes on a Plane"
where snakes are moving
in different directions.
The trainers at Universal
Animals in Atlanta
can handle some nonvenomous snakes
with their bare hands
or with the help of a snake hook.
That's what they're using
to get some movement
out of a bull snake named Victor
for a recreated scene
in the Discovery
docuseries "Deadly Cults."
It's a different ball game
dealing with venomous snakes,
like this timber rattlesnake
that's getting its venom milked
for a scene in "MacGyver."
Protective equipment usually
includes shin guards,
fang-proof gloves, and
3-foot-long snake tongs.
[squeaking]
To train a rat, you have
to get to know it first.
Just ask animal trainer Mark Harden,
who prepared 300 rats for
"Bram Stoker's Dracula"
and 600 of them for "Willard."
Mark casts his rats by observing each one
for its strengths and weaknesses.
He then sorts and tags the rats
into smaller training groups
according to their specialty,
whether it's running, jumping,
climbing, or biting.
In "Willard," six rats played
the character of Socrates,
each one swapping in depending
on the scene's needs.
One of the six was
particularly tame and stable,
so Mark used that one in scenes
where an actor had to handle Socrates.
Another rat was a great runner,
so Mark used it for scenes
where Socrates was on the run.
And for when Socrates had to bite objects,
like this newspaper or these tires,
Mark chose a rat that liked to chew.
Then he he'd put food right
by the target object --
typically his own special mixture
of nut butter and food coloring,
which creates an edible
paste that can cover props.
One challenge of working with rats
is that they're very tactile creatures
who are sensitive to
new smells and sounds.
According to Mark, "The first smell
that wafts through that
they don't recognize,
they shut down."
So trainers have to anticipate
the conditions on set
and recreate them as
closely as possible at home.
Trainer Melissa Millett
and animal coordinator Kirk Jarrett
have worked with all types of animals,
but they say cats are the
most difficult to train.
To prepare their cats to star
in the remake of Stephen
King's "Pet Sematary,"
Melissa and Kirk used a
technique called targeting,
where you teach a cat to
touch its nose to an object
by luring them with a treat.
You then have the cat move
to a mark on the ground,
starting with a mark
that's closer to the cat
then little by little
moving it further away.
Another technique they used
is called free-shaping.
Melissa describes this as
more of a guessing game.
You put a mark down on the floor
and basically wait for the
cat to figure out what to do.
When the cat finds the
mark, they get a treat.
This works nicely for cats
in particular because,
Melissa says, "They think
they're training me."
[cat meows]
The most difficult
thing to get a dog to do
is nothing.
That's according to Teresa Ann Miller,
the dog trainer for "The
Art of Racing in the Rain,"
a movie told entirely from
a dog's point of view.
Dogs react to a lot of different stimuli,
even things as small as lights or shadows
moving on the surface of the floor.
That's where a feed stick becomes handy.
It's a stick with a treat attached
and a bright green ball on it,
which gives the dog a
clear point to focus on.
Of course, trainers
sometimes have to teach dogs
to be on their worst behavior.
Digging, jumping up on people,
knocking things over, you name it.
Like you see this dog, Shelby,
doing for her starring
role in "A Dog's Way Home."
On set, the dog's trainer will
often be just out of shot,
giving verbal commands and
holding up a feed stick
or other reward as incentive.
In "John Wick 3," for example,
when we see Keanu Reeves
in the back of the cab with the dog,
the dog's trainer was lying down
on the floor of the car,
overseeing the action.
But dogs aren't just in it for the food.
They're receptive to rewards of all kinds,
including general
excitement, and, of course,
pets and cuddles.
Benay: Dance.
[clicker clicks]